qui est intéressant quand on regarde ça
d'abord c'est que alors est-ce que vous
avez censuré il n'y a absolument jamais
de médicaments
voilà ça n'a jamais rien de sexuel c'est
vrai la nicholson on pourrait s'attendre
non il ya alors paradoxalement il n'y
avait pas grand chose mais c'est vrai
que pour ce qui concerne les célébrités
parce qu'on a fait d'autres travaux
derrière pour ce qui concerne les
célébrités ont ces mines une limite on
simule ligne rouge
juridiquement juridiquement c'est
important pour eux si jamais on trouve
une seringue
on pourrait avoir une vision différente
parce que ça peut être pour leur chasse
devrait donc il ya une interface basée
sur un gottéron donc l'année les nominés
on a décidé d'écarter tout ce qu'ils
avaient une connotation médical ou
sexuelles le principe paradoxalement à
ce qu'on peut imaginer nous le principe
c'était vraiment de faire un portrait et
non pas de faire un scandale et
d'ailleurs toutes ces célébrités ne nous
en ont jamais voulu d'avoir fait leurs
poubelles et nicholson qui est venu il
ya c'était quand deux trois ans à
l'enterrement de willy rizzo qui était
son pote photographe de paris match m'a
dit la meilleure photo le meilleur
portrait qui me représente c'est ma
poubelle
[Musique]